ein hochbeet zu befüllen ist ein
bisschen wie eine torte zu backen weil
es nämlich ganz auf die verschiedenen
schichten von materialien an kommt die
man in sein hochrhein füllt und in
diesem video zeige ich euch welche vier
bzw fünf schichten in einem hochbeet
super wichtig sind
wir haben unten erst mal eine dünne
schicht kies reingepackt die könnt ihr
euch sparen wenn ihr das hochbeet im
garten aufbaut für uns war es jetzt
wichtig dass wir drainageschicht haben
weil wir das ganze hier auf dem balkon
haben und dass es unten abgedichtet
das muss wirklich nicht dicht sein also
drei bis fünf zentimeter reichen auf
jeden fall dicke aus und darüber haben
wir dann strauchschnitt reingepackt auch
damit dass unten ein bisschen belüftet
ist damit sich das wasser nicht so
staudt und der strauchschnitt verrottet
auch nach und nach im produziert ein
bisschen wärme
[Musik]
und dann kann man gröbere abfälle wie
holzhackschnitzel rasenschnitt oder laub
in das hochbeet reinpacken dass dann die
mittlere schicht darauf haben wir groben
kompost gepackt
[Musik]
und die ersten zehn oder fünfzehn
zentimeter sind dann gekaufte hochbeet
erde die richtig schön feines die man zb
im baumarkt oder gartenbank bekommt
[Musik]
jetzt wartet ihr am besten noch eine
woche bis ihr das ganze gepflanzt weil
sich die erde noch mal ordentlich
absetzt und dann könnt ihr auch schon
los gärtnern und wenn ihr wissen wollt
wie man gemüse anbaut wenn ihr
vielleicht doch gar nicht so viel
erfahrungen habt dann schaut gerne da
drüben vorbei da habe ich nämlich ein
gemüseanbau und anfänger video für euch
verlinkt und ansonsten geht raus und
macht die welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns nächsten samstag um 10 4
neues video macht's gut